[Applause]
[Music]
we already told you here on
visualpolitik even though it is unusual
to hear about it the truth is
that in recent years some things have
begun to change
in africa
[Music]
[Applause]
since the year 2000 half of the fastest
growing economies
on the planet have actually been located
on this continent
[Music]
and according to the international
monetary fund's forecasts in 2018
six yep six of the ten economies with
the highest
growth rates will be african countries
like tanzania ethiopia and the ivory
coast are at the
head of the race in terms of global
growth
now africa is a huge continent it's made
up of 54 individual countries so we can
find all sorts of situations here
countries that grow a lot and
countries that grow well less but
there's a case
that stands out above all of them and
not precisely
because things are going well
yes of course i'm talking about south
africa a country that was the great
african hope for a really long time well
dear viewer the truth is that nelson
mandela's dream of a free and prosperous
south africa it's become something of a
nightmare
in recent years things have gone really
wrong growth spanish racial problems
have returned and corruption
has spread throughout the country
even congress is actually talking about
expropriating the lands of white people
without
any compensation however in february the
government changed and one of the
richest men in africa became the new
president
so could south africa get back on the
right path or
are we facing another great african
disappointment
in this video we also want to look at
what caused those good years to end and
if the white population in the country
faces any risk
so let's get on with it
south african disappointment
[Music]
south africa is a huge country it's
about the size of france germany italy
the netherlands and belgium
all combined together and it represents
about a quarter of all of sub-saharan
africa's gdp
well after the end of apartheid and
after the democratic transition that
began in 1994 south africa experienced a
particular golden age between
1998 and 2008 the economy grew steadily
this allowed the black middle class to
double and
essential services such as running water
reached most of the population
[Music]
so with a big economy a vibrant
democracy a free press and lots of civic
organizations everything
seemed ready for south africa to make
the leap that would allow its people and
not just
white people to live the comfortable
lives of citizens
of a developed country in other words
south africa was expected to become
a role model for the entire african
continent
but hold on a moment here because things
don't always turn out quite as expected
and in 2009 this entire
process ended since then things they've
just gone from bad to worse
the economy isn't growing unemployment
has risen to almost 40 percent poverty
has picked up again and
public accounts are absolutely shattered
and that's not all the latest government
measures that the government announced
and the current social tension have even
caused
announcements like this one last march
the australian minister of internal
affairs peter dutton publicly announced
that his country would consider granting
a special emergency visa and refuge
to the south african white population
that felt unsafe in their own country
now hold on just a moment here because
we're talking about an australian
minister here talking about
sheltering white south africans i mean
are things
really that bad wasn't this the country
of harmony and reconciliation
well you heard what that minister had to
say but at this point the question
really still remains
what the hell went wrong well we already
have our culprit
we talked about him before by the way in
a video that i will link to in the
description do you know he is well
listen up
[Music]
jacob zuma
on the 9th of may 2009 jacob zuma became
the president of south africa despite
his controversial record which included
accusations of rape corruption
and even organized crime zuma managed to
reach power thanks to the support of the
popular classes who
felt that he was one of their own after
all we're talking about one of the most
prominent leaders of the anti-apartheid
movement a leader who for 10 years was
in prison with nelson mandela himself
the father
of the current south african nation and
this
well it gave him a great deal of
credibility well to viewer jacob zuma
who openly practices polygamy and is
estimated to have at least
20 children was forced to resign and
leave through the back door
on february 14 2018.
i mean check this out he was repudiated
by his own party the powerful african
national congress and
cornered by the opposition who
threatened him with a motion of censure
he simply had no other alternative he
had to leave one way or another
for the almost nine years that zuma was
in power
life in south africa was a nightmare
you see zuma came to power with the
promise of a more prosperous country and
more opportunities for the poorest but
instead well what do you think he did
yep nothing less than turning the south
african government into a kind of mine a
business that simply served
him and his inner circle by the way do
you know what the first thing he did
after being named president was well he
spent 23
million dollars from the state budget to
improve his private residence a swimming
pool here an amphitheater there
and he even had a cow barn and a chicken
coop built
but of course that's not all on march
16th national prosecutors announced that
they would present charges against jacob
zuma for a multi-million
dollar purchase agreement of weapons
ships submarines and fighter jets with
european companies that south africa
signed in the 1990s at this time zuma
was nelson mandela's deputy president
[Music]
dear viewer this weapons purchase cost
over 3
billion and the stated goal was
improving national security the real
goal though
was enriching guys like jacob zuma
the arms deal was the most graphic loss
of innocence of post-apartheid south
africa and have presaged the corruption
we are seeing today david lewis
executive director of corruption watch a
non-profit organization based in
johannesburg
and this is just one case dozens and
dozens of more cases
are lined up for zuma so in short yes he
was a really really greedy dude in total
it's estimated that jacob zuma's
corruption and the corruption of his
inner circle have cost the public
coffers
more than 4 billion american dollars and
if you're if you think that is the worst
thing
well you are very very wrong the worst
part is that he got the cancer that is
corruption
to spread massively through the country
listen up here
cancer
[Music]
one thing was always clear for jacob
zuma and
he even once said it openly his party
the national african congress was more
important than the very south african
nation that had been elected to serve
and what better way to put the party in
the forefront than by enriching
its leaders with public resources that's
precisely what he did
ever since zuma came to power corruption
has multiplied
state services are a mess and some math
teachers don't even know what a square
root is indeed the reason they got the
job was simply because they were
formally affiliated with the president's
party
virtually no institution in south africa
has been spared
from the corruption so you see one way
to measure the intensity of corruption
in south africa is to look at the
quality of housing that the government
builds for its poorest people
if the budget is already low when we
discount what politicians take not only
in terms of money also in construction
materials
in the end houses end up so poorly
constructed that some
have even collapsed
[Music]
another very common form of corruption
is seizing funds that were aimed at the
development of the poorest areas for an
example we can look at dairy farms that
are backed by the government
the best known case is that of a farm
promoted directly by moza benzies wayne
who of course became zuma's minister of
mining so one day this gentleman came to
a poor community and promised to build a
dairy farm that was financed by the
government supposedly the farm would be
controlled by the workers who'd joined
the project and who were even promised a
trip to india to learn how to manage the
farm
so as you can probably see from this
already it's not exactly looking great
he said he wanted to change our lives he
said this thing was coming from the
government
free of charge he said we couldn't say
don't like this thing
he said we must take it a frame
a black south african farmer in the end
the government spent more than 20
million dollars but the only ones who
went on a trip were the members
of this politician's church choir and of
course he kept any leftover money as for
the farm well it isn't clear if any cow
was ever milked thanks to this project
and this again is just one example out
of hundreds in recent years billions of
dollars aimed at development have been
diverted simply lost by the leaders of
the ruling party
and of course as you can imagine all of
this has caused a huge amount of
economic damage
investing in a country where any
politician can stick his hands in the
coffers or where public accounts are
highly unreliable does not sound
enticing
but now after jacob zuma's forced
resignation his party was getting
nervous about the upcoming elections and
the big question now becomes
will the new government change things
change
on february 15 2018 after jacob zuma's
resignation cyril ramaphosa another
historic leader of the anti-apartheid
movement
was named president we aren't talking
about just any guy though mr ramophosa
left politics at the end of the 90s and
leapt into the business world and you
know what thanks to his influence and
his good relations with the government
ramaphosa became one of the wealthiest
men
in sub-saharan africa his current
fortune is estimated to be close to half
a billion dollars
while the fact is that this new
president has promised a new dawn and he
has said that his policy will prioritize
balancing public accounts attracting
investment and fighting corruption
his motto is south africa is open for
business
of course he's already facing some
problems in march the national assembly
approved the start of the process to
change the constitution in such a way
that the government can
expropriate the lands of the white
population without any compensation
and if they do carry this out
investments are certainly not going to
come to the country in fact they're
going to flee
in the end only time is going to tell if
this new government will succeed in
getting south africa to join the
lions that are awakening or if the
country will continue on its path
towards the abyss but now it's your turn
do you think your country's
own government is fighting enough
against corruption well leave your
answer in the comments below as well as
in this survey and i really hope you did
enjoy this video please do hit that like
button if you did and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new
videos every monday and thursday also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine
and as always thank you for watching
you